tell us about your diagnosis well first
of all I felt lumps on my testicles
inside my scrotum and I chose to ignore
them hello for the best part of four
years Wow yes a very ignorant of my
health I told my wife a lie she told me
to go and get them checked immediately
once I told that about them when she saw
them I think I almost knew what the what
the outcome was going to be and that's
why maybe I never went liked it like a
lot of Maine yeah
but eventually when I did go I was
diagnosed with testicular cancer and it
had spread to my lungs and on to my
brain so I'm joining up with with KP
nuts next week they have doing a
partnership with with Movember in terms
of a check your nuts campaign and
hopefully I'll be able to raise
awareness for testicular cancer and
remind people the importance of an early
detection the importance of checking and
then going and getting you know an early
diagnosis through your GP who will then
refer you to your to your local hospital
because as we said by the time you were
diagnosed and you'd gone to get checked
out it had spread and you almost died I
did almost die it spread to my lungs and
on to my brain and I was in I was in I
was in desperate trouble at one stage
and I don't know to this day why why I
came through simply because I left it
too long I had allowed it through the
ignorance of my you know my health I had
I'd allowed it to spread and cancer had
spread up to my lungs and on to my brain
and as I said if I'd gone very early
like we're trying to get the message
across you get an early detection you go
in you have the testicle removed where
the tumor is on and you avoid all the
rigmarole and everything of
I went through and as you say it nearly
cost me my life yeah as you say that
early diagnosis is key we were talking
the break I have a very close friend who
in the past couple of months discovered
something wasn't quite right went to see
the GP straightaway 24 hours later was
in surgery and he is now cancer-free
because with testicular cancer the early
get at the survival rates of good aren't
they
survival rate is 95% but testicular
cancer cancer does kill what one man in
every twenty every diagnosis of
testicular cancer a lot of that is led
to not going early and any illness not
just testicular cancer any illness that
you can get an early detection for you
know you send a bet you stand a much
better chance of getting on top of the
illness go on and seeing the right
specialist the right people and
receiving the proper treatment that but
the illness requires so my messages do
as I say and not as I did and what are
you looking for why are you looking for
small lumps generally with men and I
know we're on air it's an afternoon show
but generally with men they do feel
themselves a lot I've got three men in
my there's no excuse for not feeling
your lumps and you have to go you're
looking for little small little lumps
you you're looking for headaches
tiredness all these general you know
telltale signs if you like that's what
you're looking for you're looking for it
and once you found something do
something about it is the message isn't
it John hearts absolutely thank you very
much indeed